[Music]
thank you
Overlord
[__] oh [__] did we get that oh yeah oh
yeah
that HR HR
HR that was so
that was bro I think you
actually I think you actually collapsed
my
lung did you throw that
overhand yes you did dude I saw you
[__] go like this I saw your knee
come
up oh brother Sunday was incredible
what' you do had a dude it feels like
it's been a millennia since I had a full
gamer Sunday oh okay like [__] we got
up got breakfast with Alena's
mom and then we got back to our place
and they just did the girls thing oh
nice they were hanging out did the boy
thing I did the boy thing where I ignore
all requests from my wife with the door
closed with noise cancelling headphones
and I G underwear on sun up to sun down
dude nice oh brother Sun up how did you
what time did you go for breakfast
4: a.m.
am what the [__] kind of day dark out
dude and that's as soon as that light
peaked over I did my huberman routine I
let the light go into my eyes and then I
went straight to the
computer no I um Counter Strike 2 for
eight hours it was [__] up eight hours
straight [__] up man damn dude I was
on fire really was on fire unabashedly
unashamed or admittedly I was on fire
nice yeah had some disgusting whips got
called a cheater oh that's got to feel
good yeah that felt awesome what' you
say
uh I I said the corniest thing ever
what' you say cuz my my ELO number like
my rank cuz now in Counterstrike 2 it's
numbers instead of you know legendary
Guardian Master Eagle [__] oh they
changed it yeah it's all [__] up don't
get me started on this state of the game
about start a whole new podcast the
state of the
game but yeah as I quoted my my rank
number I'm like dude I'm like 5K like
I'm not that good so this is a game that
they like this game is like 20 years old
right yeah they just still changing it
they just released the new version CS2
no these these numbers are quite
literally meaningless it's crazy the 10K
to 15K rating is this black hole where
it could be like a former pro or someone
who just started and has been playing a
lot recently Oh weird yeah no but is is
Counterstrike 2 the new one yeah oh it
is yeah oh okay yeah they ruined it but
you know that's besides the point but
you played it for eight hours it's that
good it's that bad that it's good Let me
see what the kid
said um oh and then uh had another game
where these kids were chirping at us and
then we beat them and
uh they let the slurs fly that's how
that's how upset they were that they
lost I was like oh man it's been a
minute since that too you're like this
is the best day ever yeah got called a
slur and I got called a cheater and the
two things you want yeah I said the
corniest thing the kid called us some
slurs and I go that's all you got cuz
you're [__] bad at this game or
something
nice Dad dis no that's pretty good yeah
that's all you got cuz uh you're
terrible at this yeah yeah I'll have you
know my wife and my mother-in-law are in
the Next Room cheering me
on and they hate you yeah yeah here he
goes dog [__] cheaters
that's
good yeah man oh yeah I see why he's
pissed I was 26 and five oh my
God that game was [__] up man holy
[__] no one cares about dog [__]
cheaters that's really good yeah last
time you had like a gamer day dude no
like years ago I know that's that's why
no but every time I see one of those is
it Vince McMahon you know that Meme what
the no where he's like crying and he's
like
yeah yeah we just he's like yeah yeah
and every single one of those is like
you know fortnite during Co or whatever
MH what was it like playing fortnite
during Co with
boys like it'll never be like that ever
again no you know unless we get another
one I miss Co dude I'm
kidding hopefully we get another
pandemic yeah [__] fingers crossed
fingers crossed man did we talk about
this last time the clip of Kelly Osborne
please tell me you've seen that clip
where she's like and if there's no
Mexicans Donald Trump then who's going
to clean your toilets and all other
hosts are like oh yeah
yo can you pull that up dude this clip
is legendary there are a lot of Latinos
here in this country that do agree that
the immigration problem I feel the
cringe like it's it's really hard to
watch see see it was really really hard
is it you know what really funny is in
this moment this whole room was was
gripped yeah yeah mhm if you kick every
Latino out of I can't do it I can't do
it this is like the drop on a roller
this this is the slingshot ride this is
a slingshot ride oh she country then who
is going to be cleaning your toilet
oh they
always are not only the only mean it
like that come on no I would never mean
it like
that this is I've just
wome oh it's still
going she thought she was going to hear
like a
exactly all be like yes thank you but it
was just
ooh and what's worse
is okay damage
control face in the sense that in the
sense that she this is the same face
that uh [__] what's his face had
dropping the anola gay after he let it
go over Japan he's
like what have I
just ah she like she just digs herself
into a deeper hole too in La they always
no
stop r no they're's always Mexican Raven
tring so hard to help her that that
there's there's more there's more jobs
Kelly shut the [__] up no I'm just
saying I'm just saying I've never seen
one of them that wasn't
Mexican there's more jobs Kelly of
course there's more jobs they do like
they trim hedges
and no no no Kelly
stop you know what's even worse is
Donald saw this and he
went yeah was not uh not very smart just
[__] you know he just dunked on her
the next day did he did he have a
reaction to this is there like Trump
reacts Kelly
Osborne [__] bro wait only I didn't mean
it like that come on no I would never
mean it like that Monday night I would
never mean it like that I do believe you
did she did mean it like that she meant
it like that there's no other
interpretation of that
no I'm just thinking la like La there's
lots of illegals you know
yeah yeah
horrible horrible that just felt like a
baby going down a staircase yeah no no
no no think another kick yeah stop
though